movies about Christmas have been a
successful genre in Hollywood since the
silent era such Classics as It's a
Wonderful Life A Christmas Carol A
Christmas Story and even comedies like
elf continue to get audiences into the
Christmas spirit every holiday season
this year one of the genres oldest and
most beloved films Miracle on 34th
Street is celebrating its 75th
Anniversary a 96-minute movie that seems
to be a miracle in its own right
well young lady what's your name Susan
Walker what's yours my Kris Kringle I'm
Santa Claus over the past month movie
theaters Across the Nation have been
holding special 75th Anniversary
screenings of a very special holiday
film from 1947 here is Miracle on 34th
Street
Norco on 34th Street tells the story
Kris Kringle
mysterious elderly gentleman hired to
play Santa at New York's Macy's
department store could you be Santa
Claus have you had any experience oh a
little thing soon get out of hand after
Kringle claims to be the real deal would
you please tell her that you're not
really Santa Claus well I'm sorry to
disagree with you Mrs Walker but not
only is this such a person but here I am
to prove it the cast included British
character actor Edmund Gwen as Kringle
an eight-year-old Natalie Wood as the
girl who believes him and Maureen O'Hara
as the girl's mother the Macy's
Thanksgiving Parade director and a
divorced single mom highly unusual in
films of the time I think you've taken
up enough at this gentleman's time now
come on dear film historian Scott eyman
is the author of 20th Century Fox Daryl
fzanic and the creation of the modern
Film Studio well in every generation
there are what I call these little
movies that could
the movies that nothing was expected of
they weren't didn't have big stars they
weren't particularly expensive there
wasn't a huge amount of publicity push
for them I intend to prove that Mr
Kringle is Santa Claus
somehow or another everything connects
and Miracle on 34th Street is one of
those little movies that could this is a
a really good movie that holds up really
really well
film critic and screencrush.com
editor-in-chief Matt singer at New
Jersey's Barrymore Film Center to talk
about the movie and watch it again on
the big screen
definitely not on a Sound Stage no that
is that is New York and we I know if you
look carefully in one shot you can see
he's on East 61st Street
[Music]
in this moment you see him that is Santa
it is Santa that is Santa even but and
what's nice too is he's not wearing the
suit right he is Santa in a in a black
hat and a black overcoat right he just
exudes Santa we're making a rather
serious mistake you've got Cupid weapons
you should be the original concept for
the movie came from writer Valentine
Davies who thought up the story while
doing some last minute Christmas
shopping in 1944. Davies pitched the
idea to writer director George Seaton
who wrote the screenplay and a legendary
Studio boss became its biggest backer it
was a low budget picture comparatively
for a major studio and nothing
particularly was expected of it but
Daryl zanek who ran 20th Century Fox
like a Swiss watch believed in the
script he believed in the story
The Studio began filming in New York on
Thanksgiving Day in 1946 and this was
really shot at the parade Edmund Gwynne
was the Santa Claus of the parade
I mean this is this is the stuff I love
where you get to see look there's the
real 1946 Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade
you know you've captured a little moment
in time there which is kind of nice
part of the movie was actually shot in
Macy's New York flagship store often
after hours other Interiors were shot on
a Hollywood Sound Stage that's what I
want for Christmas you're in a doll's
house like this no a real house and
after production wrapped Daryl zanek
made one of the most shocking decisions
in studio history he decided to release
his Christmas movie in June they didn't
even put it out at Christmas time it
came out in summer Sanic didn't think it
had to be perceived as a Christmas
picture he thought it was more about
faith and belief and intangibles than it
was about Christmas per se
dinner's at three
if you look at that poster they're
selling it as a romance you know Chris
kringle's in the background with Natalie
Wood it's you know two people kind of
making goo goo eyes at each other the
gamble paid off the film was both
popular and a critical hit winning
Oscars for its screenplay and for Edmund
Gwen's Timeless performance it stayed in
theaters for seven months later followed
by nearly seven decades on television
and now streaming
and of course there were several Miracle
remakes over the years
hello sir including the most famous in
1994 written and produced by John Hughes
of Home Alone Fame
[Laughter]
this time it was Sir Richard
Attenborough who donned the red suit
did that work trying to redo a classic
like this I don't think any of the other
versions can hold a candle to the
original
and many attribute that to the sheer
magic and magical ambiguity that Edmund
Gwen brought to the role of Kringle
thank you so much your honor and a very
Merry Christmas to you he's really great
I mean he's he Edmund Gwen is the kind
of guy where you look at him and you go
if Santa Claus is real this is the guy
this is who he is this is what he looks
like no he really I mean truly just
seemed to embody everything about him
right you look at him and you go
I do believe I want to believe which is
exactly the quality that he needs to
bring for the movie to work
Uncle Fred stop
and of course who could forget that
classic ending one of the most beloved
in film history again this is a
wonderful
you know sweet
perfect ending
[Music]
oh no it can't be it must have been left
here by the people that moved out
maybe maybe
I didn't do such a wonderful thing after
all
but it you know it leaves you know it's
almost like the end of inception for
Christmas movies it's like what do you
think happens there's a little belief
and again it'd be real it's really easy
to believe in Santa Claus when you see
him flying through the air right in
front of you it's much more meaningful I
think
to give people a chance to decide for
themselves
I learned so much about the movie in
doing this I they put
it back right think about it yeah I just
love movies that make you believe yeah
we popped it on yesterday I was
surprised how well it holds up and it
also it really has something to say
about the commercialization of Christmas
it was a more political movie than I
remember but you said your kids were
watching yeah we're into it interesting
they they were they were into it good
job thank you very interesting
[Music]